let's stop Blake Lively now the mom of  two bringing her unique fashion to  CinemaCon in Las Vegas and our nischelle  Turner but there it was no pants no  problem for Blake but can we please get  a third Traveling Pants do you think it  could really happen yeah I think it  could really happen  we just pitched the third movie even I  hope it comes together fans have gotten  bigger movies made Deadpool's well  thanks to the fans so Sam you're  absolutely right  I love the troll with you and your hubby  Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants is  pure pornography Wow have you have fun  we're best friends so Blake's focused on  her own upcoming film the thriller a  simple favor with Anna Kendrick  [Applause]  [Music]